well your word was consistent he was
plus three in
uh the rapid and now he's plus three in
the blitz hikaru uh you had
a good day today
not like all the games were smooth
though but when it seemed like there
might have been some trouble
you were able to pull it off right at
those moments yeah i mean i think uh i
mean it started off very smoothly but
certainly towards the end there were a
couple games weren't great the last one
was probably the worst of the day
against uh against lee and um you know i
got a little bit lucky but kind of i
think as alejandro and yasser were
saying
i was able to just find moves that
didn't weren't pure blunders even when i
was much worse i just kept the game
going and i was also a little bit
fortunate that uh the quang missed this
94 move which uh fortunately i saw when
i played e7 i was i was really happy
when i found it i knew that if i could
untangle with the time situation there
was no way he could defend so it was a
good finish and um i feel very good with
the result you have a big lead two and a
half points it's kind of hard to imagine
anybody catching you do you worry about
things like that and when you're going
into tomorrow are you thinking
run up the score play just keep playing
chess or keep the lead and be
conservative yeah i mean there are a
couple possibilities so like the first
game today against richard is a good
example of this where um the game was a
draw it was the same draw that we played
in in the rapid rapid portion and um uh
richard basically after the game he said
well i'm sure you wouldn't play this
line again he thought that i would try
to be aggressive and try to beat him
with black in the first game and you
know i think there are there are a
couple ways to look at you can sort of
play very aggressively and and hope
things work out of course if they don't
you look very stupid you can also just
be solid um you know in the process if
i'm solid i think there's a good chance
i'll win this tournament but there's
also a good chance that i might draw too
many games and lose that number one
ranking in blitz so you know it kind of
there are there are many ways of looking
at it but i think for me i'm just trying
to play good chess like i'm i'm not uh
i'm not really worried about anything so
playing playing good games you look very
relaxed let's talk about that number one
ranking in blitz as you said you could
win this tournament looks like you got a
great chance but the number one ranking
does matter to you
nah it doesn't matter at all really i i
mean to to be blunt if i was worried
about that number one ranking it would
kind of be like playing online where i
wouldn't play this event because i think
when i look at the ratings of the
players here i have to score something
insane i think there's some players like
sam for example who i think he's
underrated definitely in rapid but i
think also in blitz like
in the rapid i played sam i drew the
game and he had this ridiculous 26.09
rating which of course is 100 points
below where he should be at least so
uh if i was really worried about the
rating then i thought i just wouldn't
play the event so i think it's kind of
silly to worry about those things of
course it's nice but again um i just i
just want to play good chess and if i do
that maybe i'll gain ranking but most
importantly i would say i just i do want
to try and win the tournament at this
point so that probably will dictate how
i play tomorrow all right we're looking
forward to seeing you close it out